my name is Rachel Comey and I'm a  fashion designer I got into fashion  after exploring a whole lots of other  careers in the arts I was always  interested in clothing more as a kind of  cultural perspective but I didn't study  it in school I studied art it just  organically evolved into I think I'm  gonna make some things and see how it  goes the style of our brand changes all  the time but we still focus on the core  elements I think that are being modern  and sophisticated and playful at times  useful functional sometimes I like to  look at things wrong  it helps me design sometimes I look at  something and I don't really understand  what it is it makes me think outside the  box  I also try to be very observant of what  other people want like a silhouette or a  feeling or something so that we can kind  of try to create that I'm always looking  for a new kind of thing to try out and  learn about when you have your own  business that's one of the great parts  about it